as the government is already quite
rightly toughening up prison terms for
anyone jailed for a terror offense after
the stretch of knife attack I decided to
look at a different aspect of the
problem radicalization as he entered his
teenage years Sudesh Amon the man shot
dead by police at the weekend after he
stabbed two innocent people used to brag
to school friends he was going to bomb
them and that he had a grenade in his
pocket a few years later still in his
teens he was jailed for 40 months for 13
offences including the possession and
distribution of terrorist material now
the government likes to boast how
children are taught British values and
tolerance in our schools but what about
warning of the dangers of radicalization
as responsible parents we tell our
children to be wary of strangers and
never accept a lift from someone they
don't know isn't it time our mosques
were full of warnings to Muslim
youngsters of the perils are being
radicalized and how it is a perversion
of Islam
I'm all for tougher laws and extended
prison terms but perhaps that old mantra
of education education education should
be applied here too I agree with a lot
of what you've said and obviously
prevention is going to be much easier
than cure because as we've seen prisons
if they once you're into the prison
system you are it's a petri dish for
further added radicalization the
conditions are absolutely ideal to make
bad men worse as I think my former home
secretary once but it I think it's also
important to say that a lot of these
young men are mentally ill and they are
preyed upon by ideologues I think it's a
tragedy for that young man's family and
for him what happened and obviously his
victims it's not only Islamic terrorism
that we have to worry about obviously it
is the largest threat we have but the
fastest growing threat comes from the
far right doesn't just take away from
your point which i think is an extremely
good one on your point let's hear the
reaction to what's happened
from the Muslim count Council of Britain
if we really want to tackle terrorism we
have to start at the root what we don't
need are knee-jerk reactions from the
government in the aftermath of a
terrorist attack because keeping people
in prisons for longer is the definition
of counterproductive and will have huge
ramifications right now the prison
service has failed in rehabilitating
those who carry out violent attacks and
more needs to be done to address the
ineffectiveness of the system a home
office part-funded study found that the
best way to ensure these violent attacks
don't happen is to create those
opportunities to widen education to fund
youth services to improve outcomes for
the most marginalized communities to
move away from managing risk and
vulnerability to managing talent and
opportunity I wish that message was
wider as your mess of education isn't
the statistic from hope not hate is that
35% of people think that Islam is a
threat to our national life which is you
know Islam is a peace peaceful religion
its Islamism that's the problem
I saw Michelle I think grown at
something you said and I want to go
straight to you because undoubtedly it's
a tragedy for that man's family
sadly Rachel you and I parting company I
don't think it's a tragedy for him he
was stabbing innocent bystanders it
doesn't give me any pleasure to say
deserve to be shot I say because he was
clearly mentally ill so I agree with
everything that you said I take issue
with a couple of things that you said
and I think calling these people
dismissing them as mentally ill I think
that's a real disservice to people all
of them are well I think it's a real
disservice to people that genuinely are
mentally ill these people are people
that make choices when you look at the
particular guy in the stratum attack he
wrote a list of life goals his top life
goal was to die a martyr and to get to
what he calls the afterlife
these are people that value dying with
as much energy and fusee as 'm as we
value living so that's the first thing I
think it does a disservice to genuine
men's mental illness the second thing
you reference the fastest-growing threat
is far-right extremism so just to put
that into context that is indeed growing
but it is growing from six to ten
percent it is absolutely tiny
and the biggest threat by a country mile
exactly and we need to be honest about
that and focus to your point in the
communities as well let me ask you this
so the the race is on now for the
government because there are some
potential terrorists or terrorist
related offenders who are due out this
month one will have served half of a
four-and-a-half-year stretch you'll
still see me I can see why they try and
stop anyone coming out they still come
out at the end so there's something
there's only point doing that if you're
doing the other side of what you're
talking I mean what is interesting is
there were some figures a program called
prevent yes which people to prevent if
they think they're all those on prevent
44 percent are actually related to
far-right extremism and the people on
their courses and forty five percent are
related to Islamist extremism prevent
strategy it's a court at the moment
aren't they the government's been taken
to court about that because people are
saying unfairly prejudice the mute the
Muslim community so there's all kinds of
complaints around the as I say this
right whether it's right-wing or whether
it's you know it's according to these
figures it's about 50/50 you are sent
down you're gonna serve for years but
then because of panic or justifiable
measures by the government so suddenly
you're not going out and - you're
getting out for we've changed the laws
almost at the last minute yeah I think
that's that's a really tricky part of
the issue isn't it because I've see the
public very concerned it's about keeping
the public safe of course but there's
also an element of the importance of
rehabilitating and given people hope as
well and I do think you know going back
to education side of things I think
that's where the key really is you know
what we can do the ones were already
coming up and the problem we see with a
lot people who are in prison and if a
crimes have committed that actually they
are just as like there's a high
percentage chance
Andrea found regardless of what the
crime is so clearly we do need to work
on rehabilitation as a whole in prison
so you know going in and seeing you know
why they've been moved dealing with
high-risk extremists in the NHS as well
there are they flagged up when you have
to treat them or not or do treat
everybody the same we treat if someone
comes in and the doors in a we treat
everyone you know the same and you know
we see I see quite a lot of violent
crime especially working in London
stabbings and such and you have to treat
everyone absolutely you're at risk from
them I mean you're not told it somebody
is violent maybe so if there is if
someone has committed any kind of
violent act or at the risk of violence
we have procedure we get the police
involved and we have you know armed
police personnel who are there to keep
us safe in the department I think I've
got a solution anybody remember what an
IEP was I don't expect you to it was an
imprisonment for public protection order
introduced by David Blunkett when under
Labour government - yeah when I went out
in 2012 2000 and 2012 what it meant was
and this could be far right it could be
far left you could be Muslim you could
be you could be anything if you came to
the end of your term the end of your
four years the end of you and it was
deemed by the parole board that you
still posed a threat you were not
allowed out now the parole board I think
may have questions to answer over their
conduct over what was John war boys now
John Radford the black tax breakers but
a newly convened parole board so you do
your four years then you appear before
them and then we apply an IPP you first
be around the table this is solely for
people of terrorist bent about this
thing I think it's a really good idea
that they have to come up I was you have
to come up before a parole board in a
tribunal if your past fit for exit then
you can be put back into society if not
you're back in think if you are holding
terrorism tendencies you have no
business being on our streets one of the
flaws in the plan is that these people
who have these extreme ideologies they
will lie to the parole board because
they see no wrong in telling who falls
or whatever they call them that there
sorted and well and they mean no harm
they will lie to those people I peepees
I do think that you know then the day
the safety of the population of the
whole is the most important things if
someone is high risk then they shouldn't
be and you satisfy a tribunal or a board
or a judge I think I think that's what
governments gonna do now I think it's
pretty clear that I mean politically
this is quite embarrassing for them and
if you have two three more apart from
being terrible for the people who get
stuck it's politically embarrassing and
I think they've got to do something and
I suspect that's what they'll make a
judgement on saying is this person's
safety relief release and if they're not
safe to release then they shouldn't be
needed